welcome to this video playing color here
from from the US and is not playing the
color at least let's see how rehydrated
I am recently I'm I really got lots of
lower rated opponents which just mean
that as scored well not at all okay can
I get to play the sameish as black
let's see how I fell it's tricky I mean
especially the sidelines are tricky I
was really surprised when I when I
worked on this chapter in the book how
many wacky sidelines they are that that
are really dangerous and this was played
quickly i hope that that I'm okay at 96
is an interesting way to play while here
let's see what happens here ok write a
five year maybe does this guy have a
name in there nope named after the
player not the opening this guy has
forty one thousand five minute games and
I never played him this is serious is
crazy I mean I I don't have as many
games but still quite a number of games
that's that's really amazing that
someone has so many games and I never
played them okay
so we have opened up the position with
some exchanges and I hope to get some
good good posts especially for the
night's this is very important here rook
e1
Quincy seven now maybe I'd like him to
take him so that so that i can actually
I could have played be five I mean maybe
I could have played be five here hmm
yeah no I don't have night each form
mmm this feels a bit shaky my position I
mean I mean okay g4s office entails some
risk as well but hmm yeah this is really
a very very tough opening to play I mean
I have 95 I have the ship d 594 it's
just very unbalanced White has the White
has play himself and it's very hard to
to say who's who's players what place
more important okay let's let's protect
for a moment maybe I could have taken
and don't have for now probably not okay
but this is not necessarily threatening
something
it's just a check really at the moment
get the night back simplifications would
be welcome and really okay for me again
maybe I could have taken e 2 and
therefore but I don't trust this just on
general principle I'd like to get my
knife back I don't see see far as you
could square anymore with all this stuff
happening on the King side I want this
piece back yeah I actually think that
blacks should be ok here just before I
don't know it's it's very very committal
ok take take some stuff now come on I
mean now shouldn't I be able to grab the
material now and F form at the end i get
if i take now takes I don't really see
what's what's so dangerous and now I
can't come I take it if it's not working
what can I do
I mean the thing is g4 also hangs and
I'm also having night takes deform yeah
I think it's just good for me really I
take here is karrueche to check but 13
Queen you uncheck made and I've got
everything covered at the moment check
I'm not sure that this is good really
this is the checkmate threat is valid
and this is also an exposed piece
but what sorta see doing looking toward
look here I have neither five sg5 good
g5 and you can i push this ji-hye
therefore i can take a d7 i'm just
giving away d 7 now okay maybe it's not
not the end of the world but i didn't
see it at all okay okay I'm taking him
hmm this one is hanging and hiscott
bishop it should be six coming
28 seconds hmm unbelievable unbeliever
out of nothing I would have nothing
check I got into this nonsense my
morning from from a win to a loss very
quickly the a pond is the problem
check check check check game drawn ah
yeah well I felt it's the word deserved
to at least get a draw here mean I was
completely winning of course around here
it's just it's just completely gone I
just need a couple of precise moves
which I didn't which I didn't play I
mean may g5 was maybe crazy the thing is
I didn't see Bishop g7 this was the
problem the point Bishop c7 takes on b6
and 2d for this is this is really what I
didn't see dad still seems to be good
but here it's getting its getting shaky
that's getting shaky g5 was a crazy move
crazy move exposing the King so much
maybe I rupee 8 or whatever 95 group yet
is giving away a five-letter not that
some jam jam yeah i think it was it was
all okay but here maybe something else g
fibers is getting very tricky to play
Queenie success to winning minus
something 23 yeah yeah I was I was too
panicking that my bad King position as
Sam is costing me and of course h3 is
the the issue I mean this is so terrible
h3 have no square I need to go to f6
this and now I'm in this crazy pin but
why didn't that play b5
I was sooo and I was probably too pissed
off that I was in this nonsense I wanted
to add I was seeing Bishop g5 of course
and I wanted to get out of it
immediately but it's not necessary i can
play be five I can play be five so
there's still some justice this is the
draw okay yeah okay white needs to be a
bit cautious even a mini skirt is still
a pawn down yeah I should have played
that chance of course just losing with
the a porn Wow yeah tough game okay
thanks for watching